what is this [ __ ] air frying crabs in
parenthesis alive
these are your PornHub searches
air frying crap alive
yo with the music too no
I've seen this one
do they really do it yeah
yeah dude look at that guy waving before
they send him off
so crazy they hit his nose with it like
just a [ __ ] pound of coke before they
send them off to those spices
oh
my God getting [ __ ] up on that cajun
spice
[ __ ] let's start a company
[Music]
they really just put him in that thing
and then just fraud him up dude why why
wouldn't you kill him first imagine
imagine you how would you why would you
waste the joy of killing them with your
bare hands
you're right at least rip them in half
before putting them in there
ripping crabs in half and air frying
them dead oh you're gonna leave their
arms intact before you fry them alive
come on yeah
imagine dude
being stuck in a little vat
when someone just
Nails you with a [ __ ] sandbag of
cocaine over your head
when Harry gets hit
by that bag of [ __ ] dry concrete and
home alone too
I need to just get
burned alive yeah 400 degree Heat
high as hell yeah exactly
no we should travel man
oh yeah we should definitely it's
[ __ ] hot in here holy [ __ ] it's so
red
everything is red why does it have so
many likes four hundred thousand that's
what I'm saying why are people enjoying
that besides us yeah it's a meme for us
but like why are people actually
watching that it's because sea animals
they're like spiders
you know they're sea spiders what does
that mean the the eyes have no emotion
right I mean I guess some spiders
uh yeah probably so then it's [ __ ] up
right it's yeah it's [ __ ] yeah I mean
I can't really talk like yeah
I did Rip a lobster in half I can't
really talk I also eat beef and [ __ ]
yeah I don't think there's yeah there's
no ethical treatment of cows we had a
friends giving
and we had by the way I've never had
this before there's a company I guess
out of Texas that they make these smoked
turkeys and they're frozen they send
them to you you ain't got to cook it
nice you just let it thaw and really
it's I mean granted it's cold yeah you
probably heat it up when it's yeah but
that thing it was actually good oh it's
delicious not dry
no it had a different
it's more like eating a ham okay kind of
had that texture Vibe too oh dude
I want to try that I want to try like
actually smoking one I've heard it's
really hard smoking a turkey yeah well
well yeah that's why I'm saying we can't
I have no issue laughing at this because
I that turkey came in
gagged and bound into my home really oh
damn
no head yeah it's decapitated okay you
know even I mean that thing was dead
dead yeah and the image I have
I don't know one of our friends
he had he was holding the plate that the
remaining pieces were on like the
serving tray
what do you mean just picking Little
Pete like we ate the turkey to the until
it was gone and he's holding the serving
tray picking up just little remnants
we ate that [ __ ] clean were there
bones or anything no that's why I was so
good oh I see and and that's so I'm
picturing that image being like I can
never even claim that I care about how
animals feel yeah because let me get
some of that
yeah but at least you didn't like catch
a turkey and just put it in the oven
still alive that's different that's
still gobbling you know all right at
least oh I at least
then halfway through I would have opened
it up put some smelling salts on my
finger and be like hey
so as he's passing
[Laughter]
damn that was next level
that is a new level
I'm on a new level oh my God
I'm sorry I was so [ __ ] up no just
finally you know finally the brain has
had enough and it's like okay we're
going to sleep we're done with this pain
nope
ah
holy [ __ ] I'm sorry it's so funny
I don't know if we can put that out
people are people already give me
personal messages all the time dude hey
maybe we can got a violent lately are
you good are you all right
oh
that's the cayenne pepper yeah seriously
damn he got rocked I think this is why
I'm so violent mentally because of this
movie yeah bro I think I saw the first
one Home Alone one is crazy but this one
is [ __ ]
he almost like okay now that looks like
a Saturn yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's a Saturday the line after he gets
hit by this is so wild he sits over this
and he goes I'm gonna murder that kid
Jesus yeah dude I remember laughing my
ass off as a kid I'm gonna murder that
kid
it's a dark ass movie bro there's one
point where Kevin McAllister tries to
get into this taxi cab
and he's like oh it's scary out there
this dude turns around with like a shot
out eyeball and he's like it ain't much
better in here kid
he's like
the whole movie is so great but okay if
these guys had like if they could die
and then reanimate he killed them both
50 times okay like like what else does
he do to them what's the most violent
thing dude that was pretty bad he lights
them on fire twice
oh dude yeah Marv getting electrocuted
he that [ __ ] is straight up the electric
chair Jesus Christ he's he's
yeah he's nine he's just around the
corner odd fires it up
it's just the electric chair bro
yo that is voltage right there
what a little demon holy [ __ ]
what yeah he kills him
he killed him no that's what I'm saying
he kills him 50 times dude this guy
amazing actor oh no dude can we get
volume on this
I think I'm gonna cry laughing
foreign
[Laughter]